today I'm going to give you a really
good effective protocol
for gout and so the question that I get
a lot of times with remedies is like if
it's so effective why don't doctors
recommend it well because it's not
Medical Care there's not a lot of money
in these natural remedies you can't
actually patent some of these remedies
well actually that's not true because I
find a lot of great protocols from
patents which in this case I'm going to
put a link down below with a patent on a
certain combination but we're not using
the whole combination we're using
something very specific to help with
gout so why am I doing this video what's
wrong with the current medical treatment
for gout well the medication that they
recommend has side effects whereas
natural remedies have much less side
effects if any and so let's just Dive
Right In so what is gout gout is a
situation where you have a buildup of
uric acid and for some reason it's
building up crystals in certain places
in your body primarily it's in the big
toe but it can be in other places as
well they've determined that almost 24
percent of the cases is genetic related
but even if you have a genetic
propensity to get gout there's still
things you can do we're going to use a
strategy okay we want to use natural
remedies things that will help excrete
uric acid and we also want things that
will help get rid of pain directly if
there's a gout attack now allopurinol in
the main medication for gout works by
inhibiting an enzyme it's called
xanthine oxidase so this medication
inhibits that enzyme but I want to give
you some natural Inhibitors that have
virtually no side effects the other
thing to talk about is your diet if you
look up gout they're going to have you
recommend a lot of different foods
especially proteins but I found that if
you eliminate sugar especially fructose
and of course alcohol especially beer
you're going to be a lot more successful
and generally speaking there's two
things that can be done to reduce the
intensity of gout number one is just
drinking more water to dilute the
concentration of uric acid and number
two raising the pH of your urine you'll
have less precipitation of this uric
acid forming in the joints one more
really important point I want to mention
this protocol I'm going to give you I
would recommend to do it for at least
two to three weeks number one is called
White Chinese Mulberry extract there's
some great research on this and all the
research I'm just going to put links
down below well this remedy Mulberry has
a certain phytonutrient that inhibit
that enzyme that forms uric acid the
next recommendation is Chinese cinnamon
the scientific name is called cinnamon
cassia and you can probably find this in
a powder or a capsule Chinese cinnamon
has some fascinating principles that
related to other types of cinnamon but
it's a little bit different
cinnamon also has some other additional
properties to help with blood sugars
okay and insulin resistance
and so it can help you in various ways
diabetics for example or people that are
pre-diabetic or have insulin resistance
have a much greater risk of getting gout
than people that don't and the third
would be omega-3 fatty acids and yes you
can use fish oils I recommend cod liver
oil because it adds two additional
things vitamin A and vitamin d and
vitamin A is good for your kidneys and
vitamin D is also good as a natural
anti-inflammatory but there's some
interesting research that shows that
when you take omega-3 in in sufficient
quantities it can act as an
anti-inflammatory but it can also
inhibit the enzyme that forms uric acid
all right so the next remedy and this is
specifically to help excrete excessive
amounts of uric acid I would recommend
alpha lipoic acid alpha lipoic acid is
also beneficial
for peripheral neuropathy if you're a
diabetic and you have nerve pain but it
can help get rid of uric acid and as a
side note there's many theories about
why people get gout I think what happens
with people's gout their kidney just has
a very difficult time getting rid of
uric acid so the more you can improve
excretion of this uric acid and improve
kidney function you're going to have
much less gout but with gout patients
they're just reabsorbing a lot more uric
acid than they should the last two
remedies are mainly for gout attacks so
the first remedy is Devil's claw another
name for this would be cat's claw
because the flowers look like a claw but
Devil's claw is in one study just as
effective as viax which they took off
the market but it's a very potent
anti-inflammatory and so you can take it
to get rid of really any type of pain
arthritis pain but definitely gout pain
in the last remedy is from the Brazilian
Rainforest it's called IPO root room and
this herb is also another potent
anti-inflammatory and it can act as a
cox-2 inhibitor so that's how Aspen
works and when someone has gout a lot of
times they're recommended aspirin or
other types of NSAIDs non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories but this remedy from
the Brazil rainforest can act as a
natural NSAID to help decrease pain now
the last point I want to bring up
there's some great data on your microbes
in your gut helping you break down the
uric acid and so one thing I would add
to your diet to help bring up certain
microbes to help you fight this would be
eating certain foods that are more
probiotic like the sauerkraut the kimchi
I would highly recommend doing that as
well as consuming enough good salad
that's healthy that can feed the
microbes because there's some additional
data that when the microbes eat this
fiber they make something called a small
chain fatty acid called butyrate which
is also great for gout now before you go
to get more information on how to
alkalize your urine
I created this video for you and I'll
put it up right here check it out